are you a teacher
and a pervert
are you frustrated that you can't preach
transgenderism to five-year-olds well
have no fear
just move on up to new york city and
peddle all the creepy sex stuff you like
and we're partnering with with wpp
to put up billboards in major markets
across florida to let everyone know
we're targeting fort lauderdale
jacksonville orlando tampa and west palm
beach
we believe we're going to get about 5
million impressions and they're going to
be up for an eight week period period
celebrating the diversity
and acceptance of new york city
we would show this in the billboards and
the billboards you have here right now
very clear statement and we're proud of
it other folks want people to hide their
color we like to show our color and
that's the rainbow that's representative
of this community
that's our color says the mayor of new
york now paying for billboards in
florida to to lure people up who are
opposed to the parental rights and
education bill he says come on up to
florida come on up to new york rather
leave florida take that desantis you
want to ban teachers from talking about
sex with first graders
well new york is going to swoop in and
take those perverts out of your state
how do you like that oh you do like that
you like that very much well that's a
win-win i guess except for
new yorkers whose taxpayer dollars are
now being spent trying to lure child
predators to their state
we're not talking about gay this is not
about don't say gay we're not talking
about your average
gay guys people who want to keep their
sex lives to themselves especially when
they're around kids no we're talking
about perverts who insist on talking
about genitals with kindergarteners
florida voted to protect kids
new york voted for people who want to
protect predators and now new yorkers
are going to have to deal even more
acutely with the consequences of
democracy the system of government
predicated on the idea that the common
people know what they want and deserve
to get it good and hard i'm glad you
like that clip if you want to get more
episodes more clips more interviews
subscribe ring that bell also head on
over to apple podcast spotify stitcher
google play wherever you get your audio
podcast subscribe to the michael knowles
show leave a five star review we'll see
you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you